estamos en este tren
húngaro que es de la frontera de sajón y
va hacia la población de chop que es la
más cercana hacia ucrania y nos
encontramos con elena elena trabaja como
azafata en una aerolínea y vivía en
dubai y ella va de camino aquí y elena
le pregunto por qué quiere regresar
hace más de dos semanas fui a dubai mi
hija se quedó en kiev con mi madre y
ahora quiero recogerla y llevarla hasta
el oeste de ucrania para salvarla de la
guerra
cómo será ese viaje de regreso
en tu vida
everyone
choice
no tengo opción ahí está mi familia y
solo tengo una hija ella es la que me
necesita ahora
[Música]
cuando tú hablas con ella que te cuenta
tu hija
a mi mamá me presenta aquí me pregunta
si todo está bien y se ríe aunque yo
lloro mucho porque mi hija es menos
nerviosa que yo
[Música]
en comparación pues me
district en dubai have been for you como
han sido estas dos semanas en dubai
y ha sido muy difícil porque estamos
durmiendo de a 20 minutos luego leemos
las noticias cada hora estos 14 días han
sido muy difíciles para nosotros fuentes
elena temas como la historia de elena
hay otras historias en este tren de
mujeres especialmente algunos hombres
que van de regreso a ucrania algunos
viven en las cercanías con hungría y
otros van hacia aquí como ella